- [Voiceover] This is the
Guatemalan Beaded Lizard.
It's bite can be deadly, but
we're a larger threat to it
than it is to us.
There are less than 200 of these
creatures left in the wild,
making it one of the most
endangered lizards in the world.
Their beaded-like skin is adorned
with yellow spots and bands.
They can be found mainly
in deserts and dry forests,
but even then their hard
to find as they spend
about 70 percent of
their lives underground.
Measuring up to a foot and
a half when fully grown,
they can pack a serious punch.
They are one of only two lizard
species that are venomous.
The venom is in their
saliva and it's administered
when they bite their prey.
Unfortunately, this venom also
strikes fear among humans,
the biggest threat to these
otherwise docile creatures.
Hunting habitat loss and poaching have
forced this phantom lizard
to fight for its survival.
This is the Guatemalan Beaded Lizard.